sir
children try to run Slenderman
Slenderman tickets for the fun slender
friend a man dressed in dark
give suit-and-tie thunder
Thunderman affecting died okay is
everyone confused uh yeah so you know
you're in the right place no you didn't
go into some far-off point of the
internet um yeah this is
ah I've never heard that song before but
yeah this is SCP containment breach
slender mod got a mashing mashing the
two subjects together so ha ha I'm not
exactly sure what the heck is going on I
can barely hear 1969 I can't do two
digits on whatever 9 all right let's get
going
Oh
Oh hey buddy
ah ha ha ha ha really oh ha ha ha oh
please ok
this is I guess it in check there seems
to be a problem with the door control
system the door isn't responding to any
of our attempts to close it so please
maintain direct eye contact with scp-173
holy crapola what don't let a gap man
there's a life oh that's lovely
Oh No do the same rules still apply does
he only move when I don't blink is that
how this works I I don't know I'm
utterly confused I'm not sure if it's
just like haha what was that oh I got
another page same page okay nobody ooh
oh no oh it's dark it's dark
Oh God go over the door with the norm of
the north door door door that didn't
close the damn door
ah do you did it do doo doo de doo doo
ah ah
Oh No okay run ah
oh man I don't even have words I I
haven't said a single word in a while
huh it's just just kind of guttural
screams terror why is it so dark
hey let me gonna see okay that wasn't
this is so insane
this is so wrong for some reason it's
like much darker I mean I'm not saying
ICP was ordinarily bright but I mean
this is like pitch pitch black darkness
I guess that's the point
oh man what it was okay so that one no
biggie
I'm a keycard yet though oh wait I think
oh they must have changed the lighting
so is more like playing slender because
darker and slender that's when you don't
have a flashlight Oh
what uh masky what the hell is masky
what is what is masky I don't have a key
card anyway ah
oh gosh slender you're gonna give me a
heart attack
oh this looks safe I just hear him
skittering around in the distance it was
just an office wait no who's this all
this the elevator I don't need to go in
here oh god I can't see anything what
Doug wait what Doug what the hell what
the hell
wait a minute what just happened wait in
there now I can't get out
what's that hey I come on oh it broke
did like the cement ah I was enjoying
myself
Enderman okay I am so confused
this is so wrong it was like clashing of
two worlds it's not supposed to be and
oh no thank you
thanks but no thanks ah
what is that
I will lead him to the ark was that was
that supposed to be like Slendy talking
to me what was the deal there oh I don't
like this at all okay this is the coffin
again I know what the deal is with the
coffin is like so dark oh I can't see
anything
absolute pitch blackness I swear oh come
on there's nothing in here
ah but there weren't any other ways okay
this is it this is a dead end I know
I've been in this dupes I've been in
this type of room before let's go go go
go Coco oh whoops damn it's so dark I
think the doors are closed and I got my
volume cranked up way too high on my
volume knob on my thing broke ah come on
but there's no way to go oh wait no here
no wait
good night what wait a minute oh okay
yeah it's to the same all right now I
put it on I thought I did I guess I can
just leave it
oh I don't like this at all I mean I
don't even know what to say I'm like at
a loss for a loss for words Oh cuz
really I mean I am utterly confused my
my brain is telling me that this is so
very wrong oh boy is this an office
please tell me it is I can't see jack
give me a key card give me a key card
key card key card key card key card come
on key card no kick oh yes go oh wait I
know oh if I go back there was an
upstairs that I could've gotten um a
better key said it no I can't see
anything
ah up here
got it whoops what no all level one
doesn't work damn it damn it
okay alright okay I'm okay
hmm what is this
oh all right let's just go I got one key
card a lease that'll do something to
another office more key card better key
card better level two yes drop that Oh
No
okay that's okay oh come on here do
these in oh boy oh don't wanna be here
oh I have one of those whoa what is that
Oh God
more office I can't see anything in this
one oh let me out let me out let me up
no no I don't know what I'm expecting
you
Oh what is that
hi no I don't even know ah
am i smooth the collected pages wait a
minute
oh thanks oh wait no probably not how it
is it might be how it is it's not how it
is is it I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know I don't know Oh
ah okay that's okay that's okay that's
okay
oh man ah ha ha ha I can't see can't see
can't see anything I don't want to be
here I don't want to be here so Hey look
that I'm oh time Oh boss please save
boss all right so can I take that off
oh man all right so if you guys want
you know slender version SCP containment
breach let me know so yeah anyway huh
okay we're all last time thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation for more stuff that I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video
goddamn bye bye